Traduttore: Sonia Aprea
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Stavo raccontando a Jessie
la storia di Siddhartha.
È una bellissima storia,
un bellissimo mito.
È un modo di raccontare la verità,
e ai bambini piace tanto.
Lama Norbu, io ho un grande rispetto
per la vostra cultura
e la vostra religione.
E so tutto dell’invasione del Tibet
e delle tragedie che sono successe;
però io non credo nella reincarnazione,
né ci crede mia moglie.
Perché dovreste?
Nel Tibet, noi consideriamo
la mente e il corpo
come il contenuto e il contenitore.
Ora la tazza non è più una tazza.
Ma che cos'è il the?
È ancora the.
Esatto.
Nella tazza, sul tavolo o sul pavimento,
si trasferisce
da un contenitore a un altro,
ma è ancora the.
Così la mente dopo la morte.
Anch’essa da un corpo
si trasferisce a un altro,
ma è ancora mente.
Perfino nel panno rimane the,
lo stesso the.
Non per me, grazie.
Allora intanto, per parlare del futuro
e per pensare al nostro futuro,
focalizzare un attimo di attenzione
sul fatto che l'unico
dato certo che abbiamo
è che non sappiamo quando né come
un giorno dovremo lasciare
il nostro corpo,
chiarisce molto bene alcune idee.
Innanzitutto ci consente
di riposizionare le nostre priorità
e anche, in questo atto
di dare un nuovo ordine,
di dare realmente il giusto valore
alle cose che per noi sono importanti.
La seconda cosa che ci consente di fare
è di capire esattamente
che cosa ci rende unici.
Unici non significa insostituibili,
ma significa capire esattamente
come noi vogliamo costruire
il nostro pezzettino di mondo.
In questo pezzettino di mondo
ci sono poi anche
le cose che vogliamo lasciare
ai nostri figli, alle persone che amiamo,
che vogliamo banalmente lasciare
a chiunque segua dopo di noi.
Il futuro è uno stato d'animo.
Ed è uno stato d'animo
su cui è bene che incominciamo a capire
come meglio gestire le nostre risorse.
Gli stati d'animo vanno allenati
e vanno tenuti vivi.
Gli stati d'animo sono quelle emozioni
che ci legano ai fatti
che accadono nella vita.
Ognuno di voi sa perfettamente
che di fronte a uno stesso fatto
può avere reazioni diverse
da quelle che hanno le altre persone
ed è questa capacità
di interpretare un fatto
e di portarlo dentro di noi,
con un nostro preciso significato,
che cambia la qualità della nostra vita.
La qualità della nostra vita
è costituita da gioie, da dolori.
Le cose più importanti
sono assolutamente invisibili,
e quindi a volte riuscire a guardare
quello che abbiamo dentro
da un punto di vista diverso
ci aiuta tantissimo a costruire
il nostro pezzo di mondo
esattamente come lo vogliamo.
Ieri qualcuno mi chiedeva
come sono arrivata negli anni
a fare quello che faccio
in questi incontri,
in questi affiancamenti e accompagnamenti
che io ho con le persone.
Mi è venuto in mente
che la prima volta in cui ho pensato
di lavorare sul cambiamento
mi è accaduto quando ero molto giovane.
Avevo circa 13 anni.
Era fine anni '70,
e fui portata in Russia, a Mosca,
dove dovevo seguire un corso di russo.
Una mattina mi dissero
che mi avrebbero portato,
insieme alle altre compagne,
a visitare il Museo dell'Armata Rossa.
Ora, a fine anni '70 la Russia
era molto diversa da com'è oggi,
e quindi quando si entrava nel Paese
si restava senza documenti
e si riceveva un piccolo pezzo di carta
su cui scrivevano il nome e un numero,
e quel numero serviva a identificarti
dentro al tuo gruppo di pari.
Gli stranieri non avevano contatti
con la popolazione russa
e eravamo assolutamente separati
e identificati in maniera molto chiara
e potevamo muoverci soltanto
accompagnati dalla nostra guida.
Quella mattina, io non so
esattamente per quale motivo,
ma essendo che a 13 anni
ero, incredibilmente, ancora un po'
più bassa di quanto sono oggi,
riuscii a sgattaiolare
nel contingente russo.
C’erano file separate,
separate per nazionalità,
e la fila dei tedeschi, degli inglesi,
degli italiani e dei francesi
a un certo punto combaciava
con la fila dei russi
e io mi infilai lì dentro
e feci la mia visita
al Museo dell’Armata Rossa,
separatamente ovviamente
dalle mie compagne di diversa nazionalità.
E quando uscii trovai le mie compagne
intanto che mi aspettavano,
perché la mia visita era durata
45 minuti in più della loro,
ed erano assolutamente annoiate
dal fatto che avevano passato un'ora
a sentirsi raccontare
e a vedere le uniformi
che andavano dalla guerra del 1917 al 1922
e trovarono che quella visita
fu veramente molto noiosa.
Io invece uscii assolutamente sorpresa
perché vidi in quelle stanze
un racconto molto particolare
della storia russa,
che era il periodo della guerra
tra il 1939 e il 1945,
in cui mi raccontarono
quanto era importante
l'opera che i russi fecero in quegli anni,
quanto devastarono la Germania,
quanto la Germania
fosse stata dura e crudele.
Vidi un sacco di documentari
che le mie compagne non videro mai
e sui quali però
ci confrontammo quando io uscii.
In quella esperienza
io ricordo che ho imparato tre cose:
una è che dello stesso tema
devi almeno leggere un cinque o sei libri
che provengano da diverse culture,
perché un'unica visione dello stesso tema
è assolutamente parziale.
A noi ce l'avevano raccontata
quella parte di Storia a scuola,
ma ce l'avevano raccontata
in una maniera assolutamente diversa.
La seconda cosa che imparai
è che ci sono degli insegnanti
e che a volte ciò che tu ricevi
come insegnamento
è qualcosa di diverso
da quello che ti può dare un maestro,
perché l'insegnamento a volte è parziale
e quindi bisogna saper riconoscere
i maestri, nella vita,
che sono un po' diversi dagli insegnanti,
e solitamente i maestri ti danno
una visione molto più "rotonda".
E la terza cosa che imparai
è che ogni ideologia
è la migliore per se stessa
e quindi bisogna cercare
di stare il più possibile svegli
dentro alle ideologie
nelle quali cresciamo,
perché è importante capire
che tutto ciò che è ideologico
è parziale e manipolativo,
e non ci consente a volte
di venire a contatto
con ciò che è realmente
la nostra essenza.
Questo perché lo racconto?
Perché quando davvero volete fare
un percorso di cambiamento,
e incominciare a capire
come costruire il vostro futuro,
un po' di sguardo al passato
lo dovete dare,
e dovete soprattutto liberarvi
da ciò che ritenete essere dei ganci
che vi tengono legati
a rancori o a rimpianti.
Rancori o rimpianti non vi consentono
di mettere l'energia davanti.
Quindi, guardandovi dietro,
la riflessione da fare
è come includere
tutto ciò che avete vissuto.
Una cosa interessante
è che negli ultimi anni
la ricerca neuroscientifica
ci ha dato un sacco di elementi
per capire come mai, alcune volte,
facciamo fatica a lasciare il passato.
Uno di questi
è che il dolore e la scomodità
attivano delle parti del cervello
che solitamente non usiamo.
Quindi soltanto quando riusciamo
a stare realmente dentro al dolore
e alla nostra scomodità
riusciamo a creare nuovi comportamenti
e nuovi modi di andare avanti.
Questa è una cosa
che non facciamo volentieri,
e quindi di solito lasciamo
quelle parti del cervello spente.
Accenderle è una buona risorsa.
La seconda cosa è che per guardare avanti
bisogna essere molto
consapevoli di dove stiamo.
Perché per andare a Roma
è importante sapere se stiamo partendo
da Napoli o da Milano.
Altrimenti a Roma magari ci arriviamo,
ma con dei giri
e delle dispersioni di energia
e con fatiche assolutamente inutili.
Quindi sapere da dove state partendo
è assolutamente fondamentale.
Sapere questo significa
che bisogna stare un po’ fermi.
Fermi.
È un'attività che facciamo
raramente, nei nostri giorni.
Siamo molto abituati
a correre, a risolvere problemi.
Siamo spesso abituati
a dare per scontate una serie di cose.
Stare fermi non è proprio una cosa
che ci venga naturale.
[Ma] è molto importante.
L’altra cosa per costruire
un buon stato d'animo
che ci consenta di guardare al futuro
è sapere che da soli
non si va da nessuna parte,
e che quindi le cose più importanti
che noi possiamo fare
sono costruire insieme agli altri,
essendo consapevoli
che tutti noi siamo interconnessi.
E quindi la visione collettiva
è una visione che implicitamente
contiene una visione etica.
Io so che se faccio uno sgarbo
a questa parte della sala,
prima o poi mi torna.
Se sono fortunata mi torna direttamente,
se sono sfortunata torna ai miei figli,
e quindi bisogna stare molto attenti
a come facciamo circolare
le nostre scelte.
Essere capaci di avere un equilibrio
fra ciò che diamo e ciò che riceviamo
è un altro elemento importante
per rendere le nostre
relazioni sostenibili.
Non esistono relazioni adulte
nelle quali una persona
solo dà e non riceve,
o solo riceve e nulla dà.
Ci possono essere delle relazioni
nelle quali c'è un forte disequilibrio,
ma non durano molto.
E se durano, non sono
generative di benessere
per chi è coinvolto in queste relazioni.
Quindi fate molta attenzione
al fatto che dare è importante,
ma anche sapersi aprire
per ricevere ciò che gli altri
ci vogliono dare
è un elemento di grandissima forza,
che ci consente di essere solidi
nella crescita del nostro contesto,
della nostra rete,
e anche nella crescita del nostro futuro.
Io vorrei chiudere con due parole
sull'importanza della riconciliazione,
perché è una delle cose
che rende più grande il nostro futuro
rispetto al nostro passato.
E il futuro, se è davvero
un futuro positivo,
è un futuro molto più ricco e grande
di ciò che abbiamo già vissuto:
è la capacità di includere
e di riconciliarci
con tutto ciò che in qualche modo
abbiamo cercato di escludere
dalla nostra vita.
L’importante è riuscire ad accettare
ciò che è diverso da noi.
Abbandonare il giudizio
è la cosa che vi rilassa di più.
Se vi permettete
di non avere opinioni e giudizi,
sarete sicuramente più rilassati
nell'affrontare le scelte
della vostra vita.
In particolar modo vi volevo dare
un ultimo minuto
sull'importanza della riconciliazione,
anche quando è difficile
guardare negli occhi l'altra persona.
E con questo volevo augurarvi
un felice e ampissimo ricco futuro.
(Applausi)